- Your character is back
on the dating scene.
- Yes.
- So, trying to pick up women.
So do you ever use pickup
lines in real life?
- I mean, I try to, you know-
I would like buy a-
I would like, "Hey,
can I get you a drink?"
Or just something like that.
- That's like a good line.
- One pickup line that
I did love, like always,
it's very dumb, but,
"Did it hurt when when
you fell in heaven?"
- No!
- I would never use it.
I would never use it.
But objectively, I'm
like, that's not horrible.
- It's so-
Wait, that's actually-
That's a great way in,
because it's so bad.
- It's so bad.
- The girl would probably be
like, "Okay man, come on."
- I got that once.
- You got that?
Oh, my god.
- It was something like,
"Did you hit your head when
you fell from the sky."
It was like something like that.
And I was like, seriously?
- I dunno know.
If it's so corny.
I'm almost gonna be
like, "All right, okay."
- See, I wanna start off
with like, a dad joke.
Like, a bad dad joke.
- That's funny.
- Like, do you wanna hear pizza joke?
- Okay.
- Nevermind, it's too cheesy.
(Brooke laughs)
- There was one, we were
talking back backstage
that like a little 12-year-old
boy goes up to girls like,
"Do you- do you like peanuts?"
She goes, "Yeah."
"Do you like cashews?"
"How about a date?"
- Oh my gosh, that's cute.
- Isn't it cute?
- That is-
That is low-key very good.
- That was better than yours, man.
- Oh, yeah.
No, but in real life I
would never, I would-
I gotta put this prerequisite out.
I would never use the pickup line.
- He's like, wait.
I don't want my social
life to die right here.
- There's like, girls calling
in like, "That is not true."